Turkey's ambassador to London says his
country's offensive in Syria will be a
success he also says its actions won't
be influenced by Donald Trump who used
Twitter to warn Ankara not to go off
limits
Turkey's a big country and proud country
and then we are not making our policies
according to the zig zagging to tweet
messages I mean we did not plan our
operation according to the first message
or we did not make any change according
to the second one in do you have any
idea what a limit means I don't know but
our limit is ensuring our safety
ensuring our national border safe and
saving Syrians from the Chitauri of the
terrorist organization and creating an
environment for voluntary return of
Syrians
the problem is Turkey boos Kurdish
fighters like these as terrorists
whereas Britain and the United States
see them as allies in the fight against
Islamic state such as here during the
fall of Raqqa
it set the NATO allies on a collision
course in a war zone that's already
deeply complex turkey shares a 900
kilometer border with Syria leaving it
exposed to Islamic state fighters and
the threat it sees from Kurdish militias
like the YPG Turkish forces have already
launched two operations in Syria since
2016 one in the town of Dara bliss and
another against the enclaves of Afrin
the next offensive aims to create a 30
kilometre buffer zone on the border
President Trump says Turkey will be
responsible for all captured Isis
fighters currently held in camps by the
Kurds
but ambassador Yelchin says each country
should take charge of its own Isis
members this includes Britain even
though current UK policy is to wash its
hands of them when they were leaving
their countries they had their
nationality and passports and they
became terrorists or maybe some wives or
kids are innocent I don't know but those
countries should take those people back
to their own countries and they can
bring them justice they can send them to
court or they can rehabilitate them and
having spoken specifically to Britain
about that we have talked this issue in
the past especially if that these
foreign terrorist fighters are in Turkey
they are providing consular services to
them and also according to that joint
declaration of intent
if those terrorists are in Turkey we can
deport them I think we can be creative
and we can find some new mechanisms for
cooperation these words may ring alarm
bells in Whitehall ministers are split
over what to do with anyone linked to
Isis who once held a British passport
but as the Turkish offensive ramps up
Britain may be forced to review its
policy of no return
Deborah Haynes Sky News